das ist eine absolut spektakuläre
theorie zum urknall das wohl größte
rätsel der modernen physik von 14
milliarden jahren könnte das universum
aus einem sehr heißen und dichten
zustand der vorgang sei und in der
quantenphysik könnte eine erklärung
verborgen seit die absolut mein plan ist
und dazu aber auch ziemlich logisch
klicks uns im flugzeug bis dreimal pro
woche spannendes science wie das
abonnierte kanal und aktiviert die
glocke nur so verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's
herzlich willkommen
kein raum kein leben kein volumen kein
licht mitten im nichts und genau in
dieser scheinbaren lehre ein sehr sehr
kleiner massereicher dichter und heißer
punkt in dem undefinierbare kräfte
gefangen sind ein punkt förmiges gebilde
die sogenannte anfangs singularität hat
sich plötzlich entzündet und sich über
licht schnell aufgebläht die rede ist
vom urknall ein riesengroßes rätsel das
wir bis heute nicht exakt berechnen oder
beschreiben können genauso wenig wissen
wir wie man sich unser universum vor
diesem kompakten anfangs zustand
vorstellen kann doch manche astronomen
astronomen lassen nicht locker und
fragen immer weiter um so endlich an
antworten zu kommen eine der großen
fragen in diesem kontext gab es
überhaupt jemals einen anfang könnte es
also sein dass es vor unserem universum
nichts gab auch der berühmt berüchtigte
stephen hawking hatte dazu eine super
interessante meinung hatte unser
universum also einen anfang wie könnte
dieser ausgesehen haben und gab es eben
keinen anfang erst vor kurzer zeit haben
die jäger klicks um science im future
über eine spektakuläre hypothese zur
entstehung unseres universums berichtet
nach ansicht des bekannten
harvard-professor savvy löw könnte der
urknall und damit auch das universum im
labor kreiert worden sein von sehr
intelligenten außerirdischen leben eine
echt spannende idee auch die zocken und
wir sind lediglich figuren in ihrem game
vielleicht gucken sie ja immer wieder
nach wie wir uns so mit den
herausforderungen klimawandel atomwaffen
pandemien naturkatastrophen und so
weiter und so fort schlagen kein so
schlechtes game aber scherz beiseite wie
loeb schreibt dazu in einem online
aufsatz dass unser universum im labor
einer technologisch fortschrittlichen
zivilisation entstanden sein könnte
dieses außerirdische wirklich
intelligente leben könnte eine
technologie entwickelt haben die ein
baby universum aus dem nichts mehr schuf
der harvard-professor überlegt weiter
dass unser universum in diesem fall
nicht dafür ausgewählt wurde dass wir
als menschen darin existieren könnten
wenn also sehr intelligentes
außerirdisches leben in der lage gewesen
sein sollte unser universum im labor zu
kreieren dann wäre der plan ein viel
größerer evtl zufolge wäre es dann
sicher ausgewählt worden zivilisationen
hervorzubringen die deutlich weiter
fortgeschritten sind als wir in seinem
aufsatz nennt der astrophysiker diese
smarter kids on a cosmic blog die rede
ist außerdem von einem cosmic da wenigen
selection prozess also übersetzt so viel
wie einem kosmischen darwinistischen
auswahlprozess am ende seines aufsatzes
appelliert der astrophysiker an seine
kolleginnen und kollegen weiter die
augen offen zu halten um endlich
außerirdisches leben aufzuspüren gesucht
werden soll also nach den wie er es
nennt smarter kids on our cosmic blog
doch das ist nur eine von vielen
möglichen hypothesen zur entstehung
unseres universums und wahrscheinlich
eine sehr spekulative der klassischen
urknalltheorie bigbank zufolge ging
unser universum vor etwa 13,8 zwei
milliarden jahren mit dem urknall an den
start und gleichzeitig entstanden damit
auch raum und zeit wenn wir davon
ausgehen hat sich die frage was war vor
dem urknall erledigt aber durch die
erweiterung der physik durch die
quantentheorie sind viele
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
mittlerweile davon überzeugt dass es
tatsächlich ein davor gab doch wie
können wir uns das vorstellen einer der
zahlreichen theorien zufolge ist unser
universum teil eines umfassenderen
multiversums demnach existieren viele
einzelne universen die ab und an
miteinander kollidieren das wäre dann
quasi der moment des urknalls und
tatsächlich besteht hierbei in der
theorie tatsächlich die möglichkeit
solch eine kollision nachzuweisen und
zwar durch eine detailliertere
untersuchung der kosmischen
hintergrundstrahlung also die strahlung
die kurz nach dem urknall etwa 380.000
jahre danach entstanden ist sie ist
überall im universum zu sehen doch wie
genau erklärt die physik diese these des
multiversums zurückzuführen ist diese
idee auf das standardmodell der
kosmologie nach der sich das all
unmittelbar nach seiner entstehung
ausgedehnt hat und dies auch noch immer
tut in der fachsprache auch inflation
und manche regionen sind demnach früher
zum stillstand gekommen als andere sie
haben sich quasi wie blasen in kochendem
wasser abgesondert bildlich gesprochen
natürlich und so wäre auch unser
universum nur eine blase neben vielen
weiteren dazu der wissenschaftler allen
gut in einem universum das sich
grenzenlos inflationär aus den passiert
alles was überhaupt passieren kann und
zwar unendlich oft jedenfalls würden
sich die verschiedenen universen
gegenseitig beeinflussen vor der
entstehung unseres universums haben
demnach also in einem multiversum
prozesse zum urknall geführt doch wie
ist dann dieses multiversum entstanden
gab es einen multi kanal und falls ja
was war dann davor fragen über fragen
auf die es bisher noch keine finalen
antworten gibt eine weitere theorie geht
davon aus dass das universum zyklisch
ist und vor ihm ein anderes universum
existiert haben muss dies hat sich dann
möglicherweise immer weiter ausgedehnt
bis es dann in sich zusammengefallen ist
dann beginnt alles von vorn so war also
unser urknall der letzte moment eines
anderen universums und vor diesem hatte
wiederum ein anderes universum existiert
von dem urknall hätte somit also einen
früheren urknall gegeben und vor diesem
einen noch volleren usw doch daraus
folgt eine weitere berechtigte frage die
sich dem anschließt was war denn vor dem
ersten urknall diese theorie des
zyklischen universums wird auch big
points genannt und das heißt so viel wie
großer rückprall demnach hat auch eine
kollision ein vorher und ein nachher
heißt aber auch dass wir uns von dem
gedanken verabschieden können dass der
urknall der anfang von allem man muss
doch um das alles zu belegen müsste die
stringtheorie
weiterentwickelt und bewiesen werden und
jetzt kommen wir zu einer weiteren
spannenden theorie zur entstehung des
universums hier gehen astronomen
astronomen davon aus dass das universum
aus dem nichts entstanden ist und ja die
moderne physik ist mittlerweile der
ansicht dass dinge tatsächlich aus dem
nirgendwo entstehen können könnte also
auch unser universum aus dem nichts
entstanden sein die große ausgangsfrage
also die über allem steht hat es
überhaupt jemals einen anfang gegeben
und wenn nein wie soll man etwas
beschreiben das nicht existiert hat das
also nicht da gewesen ist auch der
bereits verstorbene britische physiker
stephen hawking hat sich während seines
lebens viele gedanken zur entstehung
unseres universums gemacht hawking hat
die erkenntnis dass die zeit erst mit
dem urknall in die welt gekommen sein
könnte und die evolution des weltalls
war wohl neben den schwarzen löchern
hawkings großer leidenschaft unter
anderem erkannte er dass sich die
singularität im urknall und einem
schwarzen loch gleichen seiner ansicht
nach kann das gesamte universum aus
einer singularität entstanden seien ein
großer stern kann demnach aber auch zu
einer singularität zusammenstürzen das
gibt die allgemeine relativitätstheorie
jedoch nicht her denn dann müsste das
universum eigentlich einen anfang haben
doch auch dafür hatte hawking dann eine
lösung parat eine art imaginäre zeit die
ihren anfang am südpol hat somit kann
der anfang des universums auf dem südpol
einer kugel fläche gelegt werden die
singularität wird damit vermieden denn
das universum ist damit in sich
geschlossen wie eine kugel fläche eben
die auch keinen rand hat diese
überlegung von hawking wird oft als kein
rand hypothese bezeichnet und ist seiner
ansicht nach der schlüssel zur schöpfung
zur antwort auf die frage warum wir hier
sind noch im letzten interview vor
seinem tod hatte stephen hawking über
genau dieses thema gesprochen hatte sich
also erneut gedanken über das fehlen von
zeit als physikalische größe vor dem
urknall gemacht seiner ansicht nach muss
vor dem universum eine gewisse
zeitlosigkeit geherrscht also es gab
nicht nur nichts es gab also nicht mal
den zustand dass es nichts gab war das
ja keine zeit gab und cloud arbeit an
stein gehören raum und zeit zusammen
wenn man also davon ausgeht dass es
keinen raum gibt hat es demnach auch
keine zeit gegeben wird er vor dem
universum nur vor dem urknall somit hat
es also möglicherweise keinen anfang
gegeben stephen hawking und andere gehen
von einer realen und einer imaginären
zeit aus demnach gibt es also keinen big
bang es gibt keinen anfang von zeit und
raum stattdessen also eine relative
zeitlosigkeit doch wie kann das sein
laut der quantenmechanik kann es
eigentlich keinen leeren raum geben und
im fachgebiet der quantengravitation ist
die quantenmechanik mit der
quantengravitation verein somit sind
zufällige und sehr kurze energie
schwankung selbst in einem vakuum
möglich in der fachsprache ist hier von
der sogenannten quantenfluktuationen die
rede sprich es existieren eigentlich gar
keine teilchen sondern das sind jeweils
fluktuation eines dazugehörigen feldes
zum beispiel dass elektronen feldes
weshalb teilchen und entsprechende
antiteilchen spontan im vakuum entstehen
können und sich kurze zeit später wieder
gegenseitig auslöschen doch eventuell
kam es ja zu einer ungleichverteilung
also einem überschuss von materie zu
antimaterie nennen das ist die vermutung
vieler fachleute dann würde ein bisschen
mehr materie bestehen bleiben und könnte
so nach ansicht zahlreicher
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
zu den vielen galaxien und sternen
geführt haben wie wir sie heute aus dem
universum kennen und noch eine ergänzung
auch zeit und raum verhalten sich wie
ein feld mit fluktuation die raumzeit
bildet selbst auch genau solche
fluktuationen raumzeit blasen die
spontan entstehen unerwartet aus dem
tatsächlichen nichts nach unserem
verständnis sind beim urknall also
riesige fluktuationen in allen möglichen
feldern entstanden waren ungleich
verteilt und haben deshalb unser
universum entstehen lassen es wäre ein
unglaublicher schöpfungsakt gewesen ein
gigantisches universum aus dem absoluten
nichts also aus dem wirklichen nichts es
gab ja keine zeit und keinen vorher war
der urknall ist wirklich ein absolut
faszinierende seite und ich werde sicher
noch x-mal darüber berichten also
abonnieren nicht vergessen kostet nichts
und macht staub und wir haben es auch
schon entstehung unseres universums
harvard-professor haben außerirdische
den urknall ausgelöst anklicken
anschauen und abonnieren bis dann bleibt
dran